at the DEA Museum oh you'll see pictures
of guys like this sure he looks really
happy
wait now he he actually looks really
happy
in 1999 the Drug Enforcement
Administration or DEA opened a museum in
Arlington Virginia to educate the public
on the agency's tradition of excellence
the museum charts America's love affair
with drugs beginning in the 19th century
with opium and morphine this is a really
funny ad this was mrs. Winslow's
soothing syrup and it's it was an opiate
that you gave to your kids when they
acted up a little bit and I have to say
those kids look very well-behaved don't
they after a failed attempt at outlawing
alcohol the government turns its
attention to narcotics and cannabis in
1973 Richard Nixon combined a cluster of
agencies and created the DEA to combat
the use and trade of marijuana cocaine
heroin amphetamines and more those were
an undercover agent shoes Detroit 1970s
kind of hot
cocaine reappeared in the 70s and was
considered the champagne of drugs used
by wealthy baby boomers they said it
energized shoes great for your sex life
and wasn't addictive and then in 1975
the White House released a white paper
steering enforcement away from the white
stuff they said I don't bother
prosecuting cocaine can you imagine
something like that now oh that is
filthy this 1990s crack house it is
screaming for gentrification
here are some spoons from McDonald's to
stir your coffee but they later became
popular as coke spoons coke addicts oh
just walk around going
I'm loving it in 2002 the museum added
another wing highlighting the increase
in prescription drug abuse
oh so that's what a pharmacy looked like
in the eighties this is a supersize
Catholic strength bottle of tussin when
you get a really big cough you need a
really big bottle and what's a visit to
any museum without going to the gift
shop we all know with every good mission
there's nothing as important as
indoctrinating children
I'm gonna help bust the bad guys right
after my nap
[Music]